I'll take care of that man because he's
my neighbor and he's my best
friend has $25,000 laying
there I got an insurance policy on him
it's against what he owes me I love the
fact that at 81 in 2023 Martin scorsi is
still making movies that aren't just
good but in some ways are just as
thoughtful and provocative as the movies
that put him on the map in the first
place his work now is a little more
deliberate and contemplative was he
murdered don't
know and maybe doesn't have the whizbang
pop of some of his earlier work but I
think he's still actively luring
audiences into a confrontation with the
heart of evil and kind of our own
complicity with that evil which has been
a big theme in a lot of his films from
the beginning can you find the wolves in
this
picture there there's a deep sense of
horror and Dread lurking throughout
killers of the flower Moon from its
opening moments until the very end I
think this movie finds scorsi focusing
more on the intimate Humanity of the
people impacted by the evil he often
examines scorsi is transporting his
gangster milu into the kind of Western
True Crime context but I think critic
Richard Brody was correct when he said
this movie is really more like Phantom
thread than it actually is like a
western it's most concerned with the
humanity of the two characters at the
heart of the
story one of the best most subtle
performances I've ever seen from
Leonardo Dicaprio and Lily Gladstone has
incredible presence in this role and
does so much so subtly with every moment
she has on screen perhaps most
profoundly though despite its roots of
the True Crime Story it's not a crime
Thriller and it isn't even very
suspenseful I've never written before
that the the overarching tone in a movie
was one of Anguish but I think it
applies here and there are some true
stories where this is what is required
to tell them in a way that doesn't
distort things for the audience into
something that is unrecognizable from
the truth of the situation yes it's a
long and difficult watch but scorsi and
his editor thma Shon maker both have a
great grasp on pacing and Flow and I
think it uses its running time
effectively it draws you deeply into one
of the most gut-wrenching stories you'll
see all year killers of the flower moon
is the best movie of
2023 I think at least I'm going to say
that's my number one it's that time of
year again where the critics
collectively decide that it's reasonable
to declare the best movies of the year
before the year is even over we're going
to start with a list of my 10 favorite
films from the year which is not exactly
what I promised in the title I promised
you the best movies of 2023 which is
kind of different from my favorite which
movies are the best in any given year is
is kind of an impossible thing to figure
out but I do want to try to answer that
question for my own curiosity and yours
so if you stick around to the very end I
have a separate list of the best movies
of 2023 and I'll explain how I came up
with that list once we get there
so just so we can understand you better
what exactly are you opposed to I don't
want to be some culture War person I I I
don't want to be
controversial okay well yeah this is
going to go right against what you're
saying right now but there is a chance
we think to get you on Tucker Carlson
this week so how much social media has
started to take over our lives has
created this very weird world that we
live in now and I feel like we're just
starting to get movies that grapple with
this world in an interesting and
insightful way celebrity influence and
public accountability are all Concepts
that are kind of evolving and
transforming in this new landscape and
so I was very excited this year to see a
very funny movie with Nicholas Cage at
the helm this is just one example but
they mentioned Sprite Sprite that plays
with a lot of these Concepts in what I
thought was a pretty insightful and
comedic way there's like 100 messages on
here probably Claire's article she must
have linked it to my profile or
something somebody wants to interview me
why are you so excited why what's wrong
dream scenario is a hilarious and
genuinely insightful comedy about
celebrity in the 21st century so many of
us kind of long to exist in the
collective dream and for Paul Matthews
the sudden burst into Fame he receives
when he starts appearing in a lot of
people's dreams is a dream come true for
him until it starts to turn into a
nightmare this is one of those patented
good Nicholas Cage performances that I
love he's genuinely great in this role
there are so many little jokes here that
really struck a chord with me I love all
the weird dream sequences and the movie
probably has the most on point satirical
representation of an internet marketing
company that I've ever seen that
recording is not
reality it is a part of it maybe if you
have an extreme moment in life an
emotional Peak and you focus on it it of
course it crushes everything it may seem
like irrefutable proof but actually
warps everything so much of life is
deeply complicated and ambiguous and
often our stories offer a kind of escape
hatch for that ambiguity offering us a
greater sense of objectivity than what
we get in real life a lot of times
anatomy of a fall is a Pitch Perfect
naturalistic courtroom drama that really
Finds Its dramatic core in that
ambiguity and when you see this what do
you
think um I don't know I'm I'm not a
spatter
analyst where most stories especially
courtroom dramas kind of dangle
ambiguity to create suspense and then
entice us with narratively constructed
relief from that ambiguity this movie
really Finds Its place in the pain of
that very ambiguity itself there's a
certain Horror in knowing that some
questions in life are kind of
technically unanswerable and yet we
strive to answer those questions because
not to would be unbearable such as the
work of trying to stitch together an
objective sense of what happened in the
past from Little Clues forensics and
limited witness accounts anatomy of a
fall is impeccably crafted and well
performed it really never dragged or
missed a beat for
me one of the biggest reactions I felt
from a crowd in a theater all year was
during a very small moment in fallen
leaves and it was a reminder that when a
movie has a smaller dramatic landscape
and smaller Stakes if it's made well the
dramatic gestures in the movie don't
actually feel smaller or less
significant instead they kind of expand
to feel more profound in fallen leaves
the dramatic thrust of the film rest on
forgotten names quiet encounters and
lost jobs it's a deadpan dark romantic
comedy from Finland that's a bit
evocative of like a Jim jish movie
especially his older stuff the lead
performance from Alma poy is beautifully
restrained and this movie had probably
my favorite use of Music in any movie
this year one of the things I was really
drawn to this year were movies that just
had a great vibe that felt good to spend
the running time within and this is one
of those it's beautifully shot there's
great music and it's not hitting you
over the head with its existential
profundity it's also something
incredibly rare these days which is a
movie that clocks in under 90 minutes so
if you need a quick engaging watch
that's as melancholic as it is funny and
delightful check out fallen leaves
yeah
wait
perhaps the single shot that I've
thought about the most from any movie
this year is this very simple yet
quietly powerful one from past
lives this is another movie that like
fallen leaves I think was beautiful to
just spend time within it's less comedic
and not as dark as fallen leaves but it
has a similar sensibility for the quiet
drama that kind of pervades everyday
life are you attracted to
it I don't think
so I don't know I mean I don't think so
the film follows two characters over the
span of decades and it's a beautiful
portrait of how we have an evolving
relationship with our childhood and our
past here that relationship is
represented through a lost romance but
even if you don't have a childhood
romance that you've left behind the
sense of nostalgic wonder about how
things would have been if you had taken
a different path is something that I
think we all face as we grow older and
inevitably make choices that alter our
lives in significant ways it's an
impressive directorial debut from Seline
song that like afteron last year cements
this director as a name I will be
looking out for in the
future why would you want to play
someone who you think is a bad person
are you kidding I mean pick any great
role Media or had a gobler or uh Tony
Soprano
precisely
Cameron it's it's the complexity it's
the it's the moral gray areas that are
interesting right in a strange way may
December is kind of the little bastard
cousin of killers of a flower Moon the
material is a bit lighter here and
definitely presented very
differently
I don't think we have enough hot
dogs but both movies are about how harm
can masquerade as love and use a very
interior perspective to examine that
Dynamic they're also both kind of
ultimately about how stories and film
can sensationalize reality in a way that
discards the victims Todd Hay's latest
work is a strange little metamodern
piece one that both luxuriates in kind
of The Craft of acting even while it's
critiquing and kind of deconstructing
how that craft can be used in a very
exploitative way the movie is kind of a
tonal chameleon it sparked this huge
debate on Twitter about what melodrama
and Camp are which I'm not really going
to get into here but I will say whatever
it is doing it seems to pull off its
Balancing Act seemingly effortlessly
tatering between its funniest and most
disturbing moments without flinching the
performances from the three Leads Here
were some of my favorites of the year
and this might be a career best for
Natalie
Portman place
what does it mean to see without seeing
you know when we talk about taking a
photo there's this very possessive
element to the language we even use to
describe that act
capturing an image can kind of impose
the perspective of the person taking
that image on reality sometimes so
strongly that the capturer is blind to
what is literally in front of them
godland is a beautiful period portrait
of Iceland and the people there and
within that it also captures the image
of a priest who is blinded by his own
perspective the priest is not really
interested in seeing or hearing only
imposing
his vision on the people he encounters
and imposing his vision on himself what
he fails to see the movie brings to our
attention with its beautiful stoic kind
of lingering gaze it's a film with a
fascinating kind of boiling internal
tension and it's beautiful to look at
with some of my favorite cinematography
of the
year in college I started a monograph on
Carthage I'd like to finish that someday
monograph is like a book only shorter I
know what a monograph is well not just
read a book
yourct I'm not sure I have an entire
book in me your husb complete you can't
even dream a whole dream can
you the holdovers is the kind of movie
this year that I didn't realize I wanted
until I saw it I love a great snow movie
and they are few and far between it's
been a while since the the Christmas
movie Cannon has been updated the
holdovers instantly felt like it could
rank among some of the best the
holdovers doesn't just look like it's
from another time because of the
beautiful period cinematography and set
design and production it also feels like
the type of throwback story that we
would have had a lot of in the 80s and
90s but which are kind of few and far
between today it's heartwarming and
sincere but without ever becoming corny
or overwrought and it's not the deepest
most profound or most impressive film
making I've seen this year but it's
perfect at what it's trying to do and
it's the kind of movie I can see myself
watching again and again in years to
come understand we never lived outside
God's house what so Bella so much to
discover and your sad face makes me
discover angry feelings for you by far
the most wild and inventive thing I
watched in 2023 was poor things I love a
movie that has no clear Touchstone a
movie that you can't describe by
comparing it to other movies yorgos
Lanos films in general are kind of like
this I mean try describing the lobster
to someone but what's crazy about poor
things is you can't even describe it by
comparing it to other Yos Lanos films
what
the range from a movie like the killing
of the Sacred deer to poor things
stylistically is just kind of absurd
poor things is probably the biggest
swing I've seen in terms of just
doubling down on absurdity since
everything everywhere all at once and at
least for me here it's kind of working
the movie is grounded by this weird
technically very impressive performance
from Emma Stone where she's kind of
evolves developmentally from infancy to
adulthood Hood throughout the course of
the film Mark Ruffalo is hilarious in
this movie The set design costume design
and cinematography are all out of
another world but I will say this one
definitely isn't for everyone it's one
of the grossest and darkest movies I
watched this year don't be fooled by
sort of the candy colored production
design if you don't have a stomach for
other Yos Lanos films this one will not
be any different it's ultimately a
strange Ode to the kind of chaos of the
world world and all the different ways
we try to navigate that as we mature and
grow as humans no movie had me smiling
and giggling maniacally in the theater
the way the boy and the Heron did the
new hay Miyazaki movie from Studio jibli
getting to witness the magic of a new
Miyazaki film in theaters was not
something that I was expecting for 2023
but I was delighted to experience it the
movie as a whole originally titled how
do you live in Japan has that sense of
profound wonder that kind of sneaks up
on you partway through the film and the
way a lot of Miyazaki films do it
doesn't oversimplify it's examination of
Life childhood trauma and how we process
those things but it does explore them
with a kind of childhood wonder that is
as lighthearted as it is sincere what I
loved most though was just the Absurd
Joy I got from just some of the
beautifully silly ideas that are in this
movie I've never seen parakeet this
scary fascist and Goofy and it's a great
reminder that sometimes just imagination
and Beauty can be one of the most
powerful elements of a film you feel
different hey you feel
different no I don't feel anything at
all me
neither if you've been following this
channel for a while you know I'm a big
fan of Wes Anderson's work I've made
many videos covering his style and
different films at length and while I
think his last few films have definitely
driven his visual aesthetic to greater
and greater Heights this year's movie
asteroid City for me felt like an
evolution in terms of how personal and
thematically Rich his storytelling can
be in some sense it's a pretty chaotic
film it has this huge cast so much is
going on it touches on a lot of things
thematically and it weaves in and out
through all of these things as well as
layers of narrative but this chaos for
me
like everything everywhere all at once
last year captured something about the
way the current world feels and the
movie is ultimately about the characters
in the story navigating that chaos from
the interior it's a movie that keeps
unfolding with more depth every time I
watch it I watched it a bunch of times
and made a video earlier this year
breaking down my interpretation of it
and even after doing all that and
spending hours with the film examining
it there were still a lot of layers and
elements to it that I didn't recognize
until I saw other people talking about
how they interpreted it Wes Anderson's
work continues to be polarizing but I
personally love it and I'm glad he's
doing his thing as boldly and
unapologetically as he does this is the
movie that struck the deepest emotional
chord for me personally this year and
it's the one I watched the most and so
you know what this is my number one I'm
changing my mind this is my number one
movie this year's list was more
difficult for me to compile than last
year's there are so many movies that
could have nudged their way onto this
list on a different day if I was in a
different mood while I was recording
this um Barbie was way more profound and
inventive than I was expecting from what
is basically a toy commercial and I was
very impressed with what Greta Gerwig
did within that framework Oppenheimer I
think saw Nolan kind of reaching New
Heights technically as a filmmaker
Spider-Man across the spiderverse is one
of the most beautiful animated films
I've ever seen and I love that they're
continuing to evolve this style even
from the first film David Fincher the
killer had the most viscerally
hard-hitting fight scene that I've seen
in any movie in a while and I loved
Kelly reichart's quietly dramatic
showing up although that one was
basically on my list last year but these
are just my opinions about what I liked
these are just my favorite films what
about the best movies of
20123 is there a way we could figure out
what the best movies of the year are I
don't think really truly because it's
all kind of subjective ultimately but we
could compile a bunch of different
critics lists as well as Rotten Tomatoes
letter box box office IMDb to see where
movies rank across all the best of the
Year lists if you want the complete list
of all the sources I pulled from and how
I used them to rank the films I've made
a post in my newsletter that I'll link
to down below but here according to as
much data as I could collect in a
reasonable amount of time are the top 10
best movies of
2023 I think everything on this list is
good the only thing I haven't seen is
zone of interest but I've heard a lot of
good things about that because I drew
from a lot of critics list this is
probably weighted a little more heavily
towards the critical opinion rather than
the popular box office opinion but I
think this would be a pretty good list
to go off of if you wanted to make sure
you saw the greatest hits of 2023 but I
think there's a problem with lists like
this that kind of try to average
everything out they can be useful but
something I realized looking at a bunch
of individual critics lists is that most
people on their List have at least one
or two movies that are kind of a wild
card movies that aren't showing up on
anybody else's lists these are the
movies that like maybe didn't hit big
with a general audience or even with
critics as a whole but which for some
reason connected very directly and
deeply with the person making the list
all the movies on this list are movies
that showed up a bunch of times on all
the lists so if you watch these like
there's a good chance you'll think
they're good movies but if you only
watch these movies you'll miss out on
those little movies that come out that
it feels like maybe nobody else gets but
which you just personally love seeing
what other people like can be helpful
and fun and help you determine what you
want to watch and don't want to watch
from the year but I think it's a good
reminder that especially if something
looks interesting to you it's good to
take a chance sometimes on movies even
if they're not the most popular or most
critically acclaimed because you might
be surprised by what you find overall I
felt like 2023 was a solid year for
Cinema but more than anything in 2023 I
felt grateful that I live a life where
caring about movies is something that I
get to do in so many ways watching ing
creating and caring about these stories
is such a luxury and a privilege and I'm
really grateful that this is what I get
to do for a living and that you've taken
the time to join me here and if there's
a movie that's not in this video that
you loved I haven't had time to watch
everything so tell me and the other
people in the comments why you loved it
so much and why we should watch it it's
a season of giving and if you're
fortunate enough to be in a place where
you can give to improve the lives of
others I think that's a great thing to
do but it's also really great to know
that what you do give is having a real
impact in the world and sometimes it can
be hard to figure out how the money that
you donate to any one of the over 1 and
a half million nonprofit organizations
in the United States is actually getting
used give well my sponsor for this video
is an organization that independently
researches and evaluates Charities if
you're like me and you're buying say a
new piece of camera gear or any other
significant purchase you don't just
trust the marketing of the company I
like to watch or read reviews from
people who are actually testing that
product in the real world and givewell
is basically filling this role for
nonprofits I'm excited to have givewell
as the sponsor on my final video for
2023 for a couple reasons first I'm not
actually selling you anything all of
give Well's resources and research is
freely available you can see it right
now at givewell
toorgle donation through give well to
any of the Charities that they recommend
they don't even take a cut so all of
your money goes directly to that charity
second give well is a resource that I've
been using for years and one that I've
found incredibly valuable and useful I
don't take sponsorships for things that
I myself wouldn't use so it's always
exciting to me when something I've
already been using comes along and wants
to sponsor a video and I get to tell you
about it over 100,000 people myself
included have already used givewell to
donate collectively more than a billion
dollar givewell has spent over 15 years
researching evaluating Charities and
they have a few that they recommend that
they have found to have a high impact
don't take my word for it though if this
sounds interesting to you go ahead and
take a look at give Well's research for
yourself and if it's your first time
donating through givewell if you tell
them I sent you there's a match on your
donation up to $100 through the end of
this year just go to givewell dorg and
when you're making your donation select
YouTube from the how did you hear about
us box and enter Thomas flight to get
that donation match go to givewell or
click the link right here to check it
out thanks so much to givewell for
sponsoring this
[Music]
video